ever wondered where your favorite
Christmas traditions come from decking
the halls comes from pagans in Northern
Europe where winter plants like
evergreens Holly and Ivy were brought
inside to cheer up the dark winter days
and while the modern Christmas tree
didn't appear until later
it probably has roots in Latvia and
pagan traditions then there's Santa
turns out he's not the only winter
spirit in Italy the witch La Befana flew
two houses and delivered candy or cold
while Northern Europeans left food out
for odin which he replaced with gifts
those traditions later became associated
with st. Nicholas a painter and saint of
children who we now know a Santa Claus
oh and the eight flying reindeer those
probably had their roots in Odin's
flying eight-legged horse festive and
why do we celebrate on December 25th
back in the day there was a lot of
debate over Jesus's birthday meanwhile
other Sun deities were celebrated on the
winter solstice Sol Invictus in Rome
Balder in Nordic countries and Mithras
in Persia for example so it made sense
to celebrate another radiant deity at
the same time because in the middle of
winter everyone is looking for light
you